AND A DEMONSTRATION SATURDAY
OUTSIDE OF THE BRITISH
PRIME MINISTER IS DOWNING STREET
OFFICE.
IT HAS BEEN A BUSY FEW DAYS WERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TWITTER.
HE IS ONCE AGAIN SLAMMING THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
INTO ALLEGED RUSSIAN COLLUSION
AT HIS PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN AND
URGING SCRUTINY OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND
EFFORT.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO LINKING
THE PROBE TO THE COMING
MIDTERMS.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENCE
CATHERINE HERRIDGE SHOWS US HOW.
>> WHILE ON TWITTER PRESIDENT
ENABLED THEM 13 ANGRY DEMOCRATS
WHO WAS QUOTE MEDDLING WITH THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS BECAUSE OF
PRESENT SAID REPUBLICANS ARE
TAKING THE LEAD TO.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT FURTHER
QUESTIONING WHY THEY AREN’T
INVESTIGATING HILLARY CLINTON,
THE REPUBLICAN-LED HOUSE
OVERSIGHT AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES ARE PREPARING FOR A
NEW ROUND OF INTERVIEWS IN EARLY
JUNE.
WITNESSES INCLUDE CHIEF BILL
PREECE TECH, WHO OVERSAW THE
CLINTON EMAIL IN THE RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE CASE.
ALTHOUGH THE RUSSIA PROBE
OFFICIALLY OPENED IN LATE JULY
JULY 2016, COMEY SAID HE WAS
TOLD NOT TO INFORM CONFERENCE
FOR MONTHS.
>> AGAIN, JUST TO GET THE DETAIL
ON THE RECORD, WHY WAS THE
SENIOR CONGRESSIONAL LEADERSHIP?
>> BECAUSE OF THE SENSITIVITY OF
THE MATTER.
>> THESE TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN
PETER STRZOK AND LEAH PAGE ARE
DRAWING FRESH SCRUTINY BECAUSE
THEY INDICATE THEY WENT
OFFICIALLY BEFORE THE CASE WAS
OPENED.
ONE COMMITTEE OF REPUBLICANS AT
PRECEPT SAID HE NEEDS TO BE
QUESTION ABOUT HIS ACTIONS
REGARDING THE SO-CALLED RUSSIA
COLLUSION CASE INCLUDING HIS
TRIP TO LONDON IN MAY 2016 AND
HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FBI
INFORMANT.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS ONCE MORE ON THE TIMING
AND THE INFORMANT WAS WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THEM FOR WEEKS.
>> WE KNOW THOSE CONFIDENTIAL
SOURCES WERE ENGAGING PRIOR TO
THE FBI INVESTIGATION.
SO THE QUESTION BEGS, AT WHOSE
DIRECTION?
WHAT WERE THEY COLLECTING?
WHEN THEY BEGAN GETTING EVIDENCE
THAT THE RUSSIANS WERE ENGAGED
IN A BROAD CAMPAIGN TO TRY TO
INFLUENCE THE 2016 ELECTION, I
THINK IT WAS APPROPRIATE FOR
THEM TO YOU AS A CONFIDENTIAL TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE UP TO.
THE INVESTOR GENERAL IS EXPECTED
TO TESTIFY A WEEK FROM TODAY.
A SOURCE CLOSE TO THE